no todas las personas van a pensar igual
genial y estoy de acuerdo por eso estoy
en la columna de desacuerdo no necesito
esas cosas acerca de los niños muy bien
vamos a pelear qué pasa qué pasa
spectrum invitamos a seis personas
negras para ver el rango de sus
creencias y valores
les pedimos que nos indicarán si están
de acuerdo o desacuerdo con varias
afirmaciones sobre ser negro
me gusta el pollo frito
voy corriendo
[Risas]
me gusta mucho el pollo frito
me encanta entiendo los estereotipos
sobre el y todo ese tipo de cosas pero
me encanta realmente no me gusta la
comida frita no me gusta el pollo nunca
lo como nunca hemos comido pollo frito
lo he comido pero no lo disfruto en
realidad no me gustan los alimentos
fritos intento comer sana no hay nada de
malo en que las personas blancas lleven
rastas
estoy en el lado equivocado de la
habitación
estoy contigo lees ofendería si tuviera
rastas es decir como soy mestiza medio
negro y medio blanca donde estaría la
línea en ese caso no voy a sentarme allí
a decirte a la cara que no eres 100%
negra por lo tanto no puede ser ese no
es mi deber sin embargo si fuera una
persona blanca y con rastas en el pelo
qué significa eso para ellos ni siquiera
las llevan bien y ya sabe la bar no veo
como una raza pueda ser dueña de un
peinado honestamente el cabello es el
cabello hay todo tipo de peinados en
áfrica todavía no creo que un solo grupo
racial pueda declararse dueño de un
peinado y que nadie más pueda llevarlo
can y west está invitado a la parrillada
vallejo
yo me muevo hacia acá
este parrillada se acabó no hay mas
parrilladas no hermanos solo vete a casa
no hay ninguna parrillada lo siento
estoy muy de acuerdo porque no me gusta
la idea de perpetuar este concepto de
que todos los negros tienen que ser
iguales pensar igual y actuar igual no
creo que lo entiendan del todo las
personas como kanye son creativas y el
utilizó un discurso creativo algunas
personas se lo toman al pie de la letra
o al al sentido literal de lo que dice y
si hacen eso todo lo creativo puede ser
malinterpretado no estoy de acuerdo con
adif no creo que sea tan creativo y que
se malinterpreten sus palabras él está
haciendo declaraciones muy concretas
como que los negros eligieron ser
esclavos eso es falso y me parece
inaceptable creo que las personas están
mal interpretando lo que está diciendo
realmente no creo y no creo que lo que
está diciendo es que hay una mentalidad
en la que es como es él intentaba
decirlo en el sentido de que fue una
elección quedarse allí cuando sabían que
podían haber hecho cualquier otra cosa
para salir y quizá habrían acabado
muertos y habría sido mejor que ser un
esclavo
yo no me parece
hablar de esto niega esto niega a las
millones de personas que murieron no
crees que hoy en día hay personas que
son esclavos corporativos o ahí hay
personas hay que tener cuidado con el
lenguaje que se utiliza kanji es un
artista es un letrista así que no puede
decir cosas así porque él está usando
una metáfora aprendido esta historia
todavía y algunas personas no saben que
fueron millones millones y millones de
negros los que lucharon contra la
opresión contra la esclavitud pero
tienes razón en que tiene que ser más
consciente en su elección de palabras
porque no todos lo va por eso digo que
alguien sigan inteligente como kanji
creo que está haciéndolo por la atención
y el dinero si lo hace por eso
contribuye al retroceso de las personas
no puedo estar de acuerdo lo que me
asusta es el momento en que alguna
persona de color o no es capaz
lo que está tratando de decir sea bueno
o no y expresa que está siendo excluido
de las comidas de la cultura y de su
identidad creo que eso da miedo porque
cuanto más tratemos a las personas como
diferentes y nos aislemos incluso creo
que será lo peor para nosotros a largo
plazo para ser honesto vamos a llevar a
más y más personas a tener sentimientos
y emociones cerradas y esto se remonta a
los que preguntaban cosas como prefieres
tener a tu lado a un racista que lo
oculta o prefieres tener a tu lado a uno
que te haga saber lo que siente y que
sepas de dónde viene genial estoy de
acuerdo por eso estoy en la columna de
desacuerdo el podría venir eventualmente
una vez que tengamos algunas
conversaciones pero ahora mismo no
necesito ese tipo de tonterías alrededor
de la vamos a pelear
la policía tiene como objetivo a los
hombres y mujeres negros
he dicho que estoy muy de acuerdo se
creó para vigilar a la minoría del grupo
en su día fueron los irlandeses fueron
los italianos está arraigado en el
sistema de la policía ese es el problema
creo que tenemos que replantear lo que
es la policía ahora y hasta que no lo
hagamos siempre afectará a las personas
de color porque así se creó lo veo como
que hay un poco de elemento
socioeconómico en la misma es como decir
que la comisión de bolsa y valores
persigue principalmente a los blancos la
a través de años de racismo
institucional donde hay pobreza y hay
comunidades que han creado esta tormenta
perfecta de problemas ya sean problemas
legales personas que se roban entre sí
que venden drogas o lo que sea la idea
es que si se vigila más ese barrio habrá
más detenidos puedo preguntar de adif
puedo preguntarte si crees que hay la
misma cantidad de restos en wall street'
que los que hay en el barrio los delitos
de de cuello blanco sí creo que están
menos vigilados sin tener todos los
detalles que necesito pero si siento que
no sufren tantas consecuencias cuando
cometen delitos
comenten si eso es muy cierto hay que
ver el complejo industrial de las
presiones aquí en eeuu es un negocio
enorme si ves a un grupo de ciudadanos
que han sido percibidos como sin valor
para la sociedad es mucho más es mucho
más sencillo darles un empujón directo
al sistema si también creo que las
cualificaciones para convertirse en un
oficial de policía son tan bajas que mi
vida está literalmente en sus manos
hombre si me detienen tal vez del día en
que me vaya a casa para estar con el
señor y creo que eso es duro para mí
porque no quiero desconfiar de la
policía pero son tan desconfiados con
nosotros que podrían matarme
mi padre trabajó en la policía y él es
un hombre de color
y hay algunos policías que no se sienten
así sin embargo creo que muchos de esto
tiene que ver con el miedo y el temor a
los negros así que creo que se abordamos
ese nivel de miedo y dejamos de
presentarlos como grandes y temibles eso
lo cambiaría todo
actúa de una forma diferente con las
personas que no son negras 3 2 1
haces el monto al cual en el gestión mío
qué haces
estoy de acuerdo en que actuó de forma
diferente con las personas que no son
negras solo porque la américa
corporativa no quiere oírme hablar con
mi argot y no estoy contenta con ello me
gustaría que fuera diferente pero siento
que tengo que hacerlo para encajar en
ese grupo estoy en desacuerdo yo soy yo
donde quiera que vaya soy un hombre
negro orgulloso y voy a contar mi verdad
todos los días de la semana si no te
gusta no es mi problema es cosa tuya
siento que es un prejuicio para
cualquiera que esté cerca de ellos no
ser mi auténtico yo solo porque soy
negro y mis amigos blancos quieren salir
conmigo quieren algo de chispa
así que si yo actúo diferente son dos
cosas diferentes una cosa es te estás
cambiando a ti mismo o estás cambiando
como comunicas quién eres y yo cambio la
forma de comunicar lo que soy pero sigo
siendo el mismo tienes una voz blanca
tengo una voz blanca sé completamente
que soy un hombre negro confía en mí
toda persona negra que vive en los
estados unidos puede cambiar de registro
pero entonces tienes que mover
la pregunta era si actuó de forma
diferente cuando estoy en otro lugar
examine o escuché cómo voy a ser
aceptado
siempre estoy cambiando eso significa
que siempre estoy dispuesto a otra cosa
es lo que digo se si quiere ser aceptado
tienes que ser tú muchachos cuando
hablan del cambio de registro quieren
decir que cambian las palabras que dicen
o su tono de voz cambio como lo digo y
cambio lo que digo entraré a una reunión
de negocios de una forma diferente a
cómo entro a la cancha de baloncesto así
que soy yo el que cambia para adaptarse
al escenario en beneficio del objetivo
final y no lo veo como algo negativo lo
veo como si me centrará en el objetivo
final pero siento que la sociedad
americana ha hecho que las personas
negras operen de esa manera nadie le
pide a los blancos que cambien el
registro pueden ser blancos en eeuu en
china donde sea acepte en el mundo como
si fuera una visa pero yo soy el único
que tiene que ir por ahí y decir hola
qué tal estoy orgulloso de ser negro
o si está bien me alegra que estemos de
acuerdo sí sí y me encanta que podamos
tener estas discusiones y seguir yendo a
casa sabiendo que somos una familia me
encanta ser negra me encanta que nos
expresemos de muchas maneras y no de
sólo una estoy orgullosa de ser mestiza
y también de mi mitad inmigrantes de mi
mitad negra mis antepasados trajeron su
propia libertad de la esclavitud y me
encanta ser negro no lo querría de otra
manera es decir si presenta sus retos
pero no podría concebir ser otra cosa
estoy muy orgulloso de ser afroamericano
en eeuu
esto fue divertido gracias a dios
cuídense eso estuvo bien
me gustó la sección le hiciera venir
otra vez hallar solo con estos temas
jubilee